they've been testing the water for a
while but now the Liberal Democrats have
formally taken the plunge as enticing as
the beach may have been delegates were
instead gathered inside the conference
hall to vote on the party's brexit
policy the raised hands a show of
overwhelming endorsement for their
leaders plan to stop it altogether if we
end up in a general election that will
be all about brexit the Liberal
Democrats want to stop brexit and so
electing a Liberal Democrat majority
government we would revoke article 50
but even within the self-proclaimed
party of remain there were some who had
reservations this strikes me as an
undeliverable promise and you may
remember as liberal Democrats we've
we've had one of those before I don't
want to be in a position again where the
Liberal Democrats have promised
something and done something else and I
think there's a real danger of that with
revoking article 50 the party's former
leader who never quite made the leap to
endorsing revoked while at the helm
that's the position we must stop and we
will for speaking to Sky News he said
there was still a chance Parliament
could back a deal before as Johnson
accepts the second referendum in the
terms the key development which may now
happen is that he will take the only
sensible way out which is to try to get
some kind of deal and with there's a
background music about the Irish
backstop and if he does that and if it's
subject to a people's voter referendum
way well get through Parliament the
Parliament currently suspended that will
be for the weeks ahead right now the
focus here is on the party's own
fortunes
the commitment to revoke article 50 is
no doubt I catching but it comes with a
major caveat it means that the Liberal
Democrats would need to win a majority
in the general election and even some of
the most optimistic delegates here would
surely concede that at the moment at
least that looks unlikely but the Lib
Dem leadership believe the new-look
parliamentary party reflects a deeper
shift which could see traditional labour
and Tory voters also make the switch
last night former Conservative Minister
Sam Jima became the latest new recruit
the stark reality was that I had to face
the fact that the Conservative Party is
in a different place and if I want to
fight in politics for liberal values
that millions of people want to see in
our politics then the Conservative Party
is no longer the place to do so but how
have the defecting MPs been received by
long-serving members I have a few
concerns about why people have joined us
and whether they are true Liberal
Democrats but time will tell out that I
think it's added a new energy to
comprehensive into conference lots of
times the last few years and this is
probably the happiest and buzziest one I
can remember going to some reservations
with some but I really hope to see them
grow and see what they make of being in
a really liberal environment the
politics around brexit are moving fast
but for all the feelgood factor the Lib
Dems are experiencing right now it's
still not at all clear